oh we're going
yogurt there are 400,000 men trapped in
one place on a beach that backs to the
sea the enemy closing in on Alden and
it's just a matter of time before they
face
surrender or annihilation the fact that
this story does not end in either
surrender or annihilation this all makes
it one of the greatest stories in human
history there's no hiding from the Sun
we straight away started talking about a
big format we have big law for the big
four months I mean especially IMAX you
know it's a very visceral window to the
world you know in many ways it's the
best form of out there if somebody had
said to us six years ago you know go off
and make a film about the evacuation of
Dunkirk using only large format cameras
I think we would have thought that was
an insane thing to do but because we've
done so much of that work on
interstellar and the direct movies we
were equipped to do it
and you know we're able to maximize the
format and really get everything that we
want to come in seventy something
percent of the film is the full IMAX
format because it is the most beautiful
way to what your movie it's a treat if
you can see it in that format the
immersive quality of the image is second
to none we really try and create the
sensation and that I would describe it
as virtual reality mounted goggles
a huge challenge is the size and weight
of the cameras so our feeling was if we
could finally do it physically to pay
off well worth it I really wanted to
make that camera work as any other
camera you would use you know handheld
and it is very sort of intuitive an
impulsive way that you can use a film
camera with the storage structure on
dunkirk you have a lot of different
points of view so rules you know in the
cockpit lisbeth are up in the air
always down on you know with the guys
and Reacher and in water with them rules
on this you're crossing a channel we
started to invent stuff to make it
possible for us to put the camera on
planes and in the cockpits engineering
special lenses that would put the lenses
in certain places where it was
impossible for a camera to be it was
massively important to us to do that
because we really wanted to be able to
get our actors up into the air the shots
where you see one of the actors in a
Spitfire and then just beyond them
another Spitfire there's really no way
that you could create that in a computer
you always end up thinking about things
that are impossible and then you know
trying to make them possible we made it
work these amazing massive cameras a
very very visceral experience a really
tactile stairs of being there in these
events the audience really gets the
benefit of that large canvas
particularly an IMAX I think audiences
are really going to feel the Jeopardy
and the vulnerability that they felt
I'm going to put yourself in a seat and
I'm executing you look at it you know
you see what it does to you you see what
it does to your emotion I just want
people to be completely blown away with
what they just say I want to give people
a really intense ride really put people
there allow them to feel what that
experience would be like
you